Where does a fish keep its money?
In the river bank!
This dress costs a 'hundred bucks'.
This phone costs '10,000 bucks'.
We usually hear people describing money, as bucks right?
But ever wondered how this slang for money originated?
Curious?
Time to find out.
First of all,
can you tell me what buck literally means?
It usually refers to a male deer!
But what does Deer have to do with Money?
For this let us move back to America of the early 18th century.
At that time, the US dollar was not invented,
and thus people traded in the form of goods or commodities.
This kind of trade is referred to as the Barter system.
The simplest example would be exchange of a boat for a bicycle.
Or exchange of bread for butter and so on.
In some parts of America,
Deerskin was one of the most highly valued commodity.
This was usually due to its usefulness in clothing and moccasins,
and also because of its high quality.
Therefore, trade was usually carried in the form of deerskin
which was referred to as buckskin.
People at that time used to value things in terms of buckskin.
For instance, 10 kilograms of rice for three buckskin,
a pair of moccasins for five buckskin and so on.
One recorded example of this, is where a cask of whiskey
was traded by the European settlers to the native Americans
in exchange of five buckskins.
As time passed, buckskin was shortened to bucks.
Around the year 1792,
US Dollars were introduced,
which soon became the main medium of exchange.
Although people stopped trading in buckskins,
the word BUCK still seemed to prevail in the minds of the people
as a reference for money.
So this is how the slang 'Buck' for money
originated in the US, and then spread out worldwide.
So this was about the 'BUCK'.
The word 'buck' is just a slang as you know now,
but every nation has its own currency.
For example, US has Dollars,
Japan has Yen,
India has Rupee and so on...
On these lines,
have you ever wondered why different nations have different currencies?
Why can't there be a single currency worldwide?
Are there plans to build a single currency globally?
Well... this one is your Kyu Box to explore.
Let us know your findings in the comment section.
To be a part of our massive learning community,
do subscribe to our channel.